[Music]
and finally is drinking in the office
really all that bad can actually help to
bring a team together
i'm joined now by rory sutherland the
spectators wikiman columnist
rory thank you for joining spectator tv
now in your calling for the magazine
this week you have discussed
workplace drinking a topical subject at
the moment are you for or against
i suppose i'm not necessarily
comfortable with what went on in downing
street by any means but i'm not quite
comfortable either with the way in which
it's reported
as though any consumption of alcohol in
the workplace
necessarily means that there's a party
going on
and that it's somehow an egregious
activity
and the reason i'd say that in
particular is much of this reporting
most of it in fact is being done by
journalists who are hardly completely
innocent on the question of workplace
drinking themselves
and
all i can say is it's complicated i
would like a more forensic investigation
of what went on i would regard music
dancing that kind of party thing as
wholly unacceptable not necessarily
because it's illegal but because it's in
bad faith
on the other hand i don't regard it as
acceptable if you take that photograph
of the downing street garden taken from
an upper window
i don't regard that as having any
evidential value whatsoever it shows
some people in a garden
the purpose of the legislation was to
prevent people mixing with strangers
those people were not strangers to each
other they were in a secure space they'd
chosen to go outside which in
terms of epidemiological behavior was
probably a sensible thing to do and one
or two of them were consuming wine
now
i don't quite think it's fair
uh for that to be used to rile the
populace i accept the fact that ninety
percent of people are rarely if ever
allowed to drink in the workplace
on the other hand there are plenty of
cultures including by the way medicine
where quite a lot of valuable
information transmission takes place by
people drinking together after work
in businesses where you're not paid
overtime there's a kind of informal
exchange where you stay a little bit
late you do some work you talk about
work you enjoy a drink
now the culture will vary just as
drinking culture varies massively from
country to country i mean the last two
or three presidents of the united states
have been t total for example
okay
it varies enormously from one workplace
to another yes i'm completely open to
the argument that political culture is
far too boozy i work in advertising and
i think the same thing myself i think
it's obsessively gregarious dominated by
kind of fomo
and absolutely obsessed
uh with attending endless drinks parties
i don't think that's healthy
at the same time i don't think it's
entirely fair to vilify the behavior
completely
for one thing people working very very
hard at conditions of some personal risk
are entitled to winds down briefly from
time to time
isn't the explosive issue here that we
were not under normal conditions in fact
the police were being sent after people
who were daring to have somebody into
their garden have somebody into their
home even have somebody into their
office that wasn't a necessary work
event it isn't the issue that some
people in number 10 decided to have some
wine at the end of the day is that they
explicitly made it against the rules for
anybody else to do so
the reason i mean this this comes down
to an interesting thing which is to what
extent you practice deontology
and to what extent you practice
consequentialism okay
now the reason parties were banned was
not because they
uh allowed for the consumption of
alcohol nothing about the legislation
said anything about what you did in your
own home you could be completely sozzled
the entire time under lockdown if
conditions allowed the purpose for
banning
probably by yourself if you were living
on your own
okay
now if these people are already mixing
they're in a household
if you would spend at a lockdown living
alone undoubtedly those conditions were
much much tougher on you than if you
lived in an ashram or a commune
i wouldn't be surprised to hear that for
example the staff of windsor castle or
the staff of buckingham palace had
drinks together during lockdown
because they occupied the same space
okay the purpose of the law was not to
prevent people having as good a time as
was feasibly possible under the
circumstances it was to prevent people
becoming exposed to additional people
other than those to whom they
necessarily have to be in contact with
and so i think there's something we have
at the rule of law for a reason um and
you might argue that the conditions in a
workplace once you have determined that
these people have to interact in an
office
okay
effectively mean that it isn't relevant
to prevent people drinking wine with
people with whom they're already
communing
now i i
okay i get the fact that it seems unfair
but then so much of this was monstrously
unfair it's not just that it was a bit
unfair or a bit annoying or a bit lonely
or a bit sad that people had to
basically stay inside and not see other
people i don't remember the guidance
coming out from number 10 saying
actually it's fine if you go out into
the park with a bunch of your friends or
a bunch of your family and socialize
because we know from a health and safety
perspective now that this virus doesn't
really transmit outside in fact that
weekend they had the police tweeting out
do not break the rules essentially do
not enjoy the good weather with your
mates make sure that you abide by the
law and this isn't an issue of drinking
it's not an issue of having a bit of fun
which i agree rory can be a great time
of course under the appropriate
circumstances it's the fact that the
people who were making these laws have
been found to have been breaking them
and they didn't update the laws for
everybody else so it wasn't as if people
could enjoy these good times as well
um well other people couldn't enjoy the
fact if it involved meeting other people
although on the very same day the
beaches were fairly crowded let's be
honest okay it wasn't as if the public
were being entirely uh obedient outdoors
i've already written a piece in the
spectator which explained why garden
parties
had to be banned even when it was known
that outdoor transmission was
comparatively rare which is the simple
fact that an outdoor garden party turns
into an indoor party
that's what tends to happen towards the
end of the evening when it gets cold
when people need to leave the loo in
this case
if these people were not meeting anybody
new if they'd invited people from
adjacent buildings absolutely clear
that's an absolutely clear breach of the
rules here it's a little more ambiguous
the second question to ask is not
necessarily about whether it's good or
bad but whether this deserves the volume
of media attention that it's getting
and it strikes me to some extent that we
don't actually need the metaverse
because the media already creates it for
us a kind of parallel reality where
attention is paid to things to the
extent to which it suits a pre-ordained
narrative
and i don't think the record by the way
of journalism here is all that great
robert cialdini does a lot of work which
shows that most media bias is not the
result of a biased depiction of opinions
it's the relative prominence that is
given to different stories that's the
greater vehicle of media bias okay
now you can imagine a world in which a
blair regime or another regime to whom
journalists were better disposed had
committed the same infractions where
this would have received much less
attention would have ended up on page
five
okay
i don't think this is an area which
necessarily should be dominating the
news cycle when you have you know a
potential invasion of ukraine on the
cards
okay
and there's something about the
incessant attention given to the story
which doesn't seem to me entirely in
proportion to the infractions committed
well rory after that discussion i think
you've earned yourself a drink thanks
for joining spectator tv
and that's it for this week if you've
enjoyed this episode don't forget to
subscribe to the spectator's youtube
channel just click the subscribe button
at the bottom of this video and tap the
bell icon to make sure you never miss an
episode thanks for watching and do join
us again next week
[Music]
you